Je suis allé affronter le mari.
Madame, cela fait deux semaines,
et la femme n'a pas pleuré depuis.
Merci de m'avoir donné une voix. »
(Applaudissements)
Toutes ces histoires touchantes
montrent que nous avons arrivons à quelque chose avec les hommes,
mais pour obtenir un monde où les hommes et les femmes sont égaux
il ne faut pas juste rallier les hommes à la cause.
Nous voulons un vrai changement qui puisse rendre égales
les réalités politiques, économiques et sociales pour les hommes et les femmes.
Nous demandons aux hommes des actions concrètes
les appelant à intervenir sur un plan personnel
pour changer leur comportement.
Nous appelons les gouvernements, les entreprises, les universités,
à changer leurs politiques.
Les hommes qui dirigent doivent devenir des modèles
et des vecteurs de changement au sein de leur propre institution.
Un nombre d'hommes importants et de dirigeants se sont mobilisés
et se sont engagés dans des actions concrètes pour HeForShe.
Autre exemple de belle réussite,
une grande entreprise française dans le domaine du tourisme, Accor,
s'est engagée à éliminer les différences de salaires
pour ses 180 000 employés d'ici 2020.
(Applaudissements)
La Suède,
avec son actuel gouvernement féministe
s'est engagée à supprimer les discriminations d'emploi et de salaire
pour tous ses citoyens, et ce au cours de ce mandat.
Au Japon, l'université de Nagoya
construit, dans le cadre de HeForShe,
ce qui va devenir l'un des plus grands centres de recherche sur le genre.
Aujourd'hui, 8 mois après,
un mouvement est en marche.
Nous voyons des hommes se manifester, venant de tous horizons,
venant des 4 coins du monde,
du secrétaire général des Nations-Unies Ban Ki Moon,
au secrétaire général de l'OTAN, et à celui du Conseil Européen,
du Premier Ministre du Bhoutan
au Président de la Sierra Leone.
Rien qu'en Europe, tous les hommes de la Commission Européenne
et les membres des gouvernements suédois et islandais
ont adhéré à HeForShe.
En Islande, un homme sur 20 a rejoint le mouvement.
Le cri de ralliement de notre ambassadrice, Emma Watson,
a suscité plus de 5 milliards de références dans les médias
mobilisant des centaines de milliers d'étudiants à travers le monde
pour créer plus d'une centaine d'associations étudiantes HeForShe.
C'est le début de la vision qu'a HeForShe
pour le monde que nous voulons voir.
Einstein a dit :
« Un être humain est une partie d'un tout...
Il s'expérimente lui-même,
ses pensées et ses émotions
comme quelque chose qui est séparé du reste...
Cette illusion est une sorte de prison pour nous...
Notre tâche doit être de nous libérer nous-même de cette prison
en étendant notre cercle de compassion... »
Si les femmes et les hommes font partie d'un tout,
comme le suggère Einstein,
j'ai bon espoir que HeForShe puisse nous aider à réaliser
que ce n'est pas notre genre qui nous définit,
mais finalement l'humanité que nous partageons.
HeForShe puise dans les rêves des hommes et des femmes,
les rêves que nous avons pour nous-mêmes,
et les rêves que nous avons pour nos familles, nos enfants,
nos amis, nos communautés.
C'est de cela qu'il s'agit.
HeForShe est là pour améliorer notre quotidien à tous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)